für diesen Burrito muss man eigentlich
in die USA fliegen es sei denn man ist
in Frankfurt wir testen chipole F es ist
mir mal wieder eine Freude hier mit dir
zu stehen und ich muss sagen wo sollten
wir sonst sein außer in mein hatten ne
man sagt ja nicht umsonst einzige Stadt
in Deutschland mit einer Skyline einzige
stad mit chipole wir sehen es hinter uns
chipole Mexican Grill für die
Frankfurter wahrscheinlich keine
Besonderheit ich selbst war einmal hier
vor vielen Jahren du warst noch nie hier
oder noch nie tatsächlich ne hab es erst
durch dich erfahren Schand über mein
Haupt ja siehst du mal ich bin
vielleicht bin ich doch der Frankfurter
ne mus musser lassen kein Spaß also ganz
ehrlich leute ich bin sehr sehr Hype
weil ich persönlich liebe chipole es ist
einfach in Deutschland relativ schwer
ein guten Burrito zu bekommen und kann
jeder sagen was er will für mich sind
chipoli Burritos eine Bank die sind
immer geil viele von euch werden es
nicht kennen deshalb gehen wir einfach
mal rein und gucken was diese
amerikanische buritookette zu bieten hat
los geht's Skyline Plaza mittlerweile
gibt's den Laden auch in der Mai Zeil
also zweimal in Frankfurt aber Sonnen
Fehlanzeige nirgendwo in Deutschland ich
finde das wirklich so verrückt dass wir
gerade reinlaufen das letzte Mal bei
chipole war ich vor d Jahren in New York
und jetzt einfach in Frankfurt zi
Stunden gefahren statt 10 Stunden
geflogen ich weiß gar nicht warum ich be
der Fastfood Tour wir war ja auch
gemeinsam in LA ich habe ja da auch
verschiedene Fastfood Konzepte mir
angeschaut ich hatte das nicht auf dem
Schirm sag ich ehrlich weil ich sag dir
ich bin auch immer so enttäuscht gewesen
von tacobell weißt so dann habe ich mir
gedacht okay das kann als Kette nicht
funktionieren kannst du auch nicht
vergleichen chicole Burrito ist wirklich
wirklich gut zumindest so wie ich in
Erinnerung habe schauen wir mal was hier
alles auf der Karte steht weil ich glaub
es gibt noch viel mehr als Burrito man
kann auswehlen zwischen Burrito Bowl
Salat und Tacos sagen wir nehmen einfach
von allem eins oder weißt du was ich
jetzt erwarte hätte Tiefkühlbeutel auf
irgendwie in irgendeiner warm gemacht
weiß ich nicht drauf geklatscht
eingerollt Ciao ja was mir direkt
aufgefallen ist hier rennen 6 7 a Leute
rum das ist auf jeden Fall auch krass
ich glaube hier kannst auch schon
zwischendurch mal richtig abgehen und in
Amerika gilt chipole auch so als das
gesunde Fastfood wir reden nicht lang
wir stellen uns mal was zusammen und
verstellen uns was Schönes machen mal
den Anfang mit einem Burrito bitte
Freunde schaut euch bitte mal diese
ausbäol hier an wir haben zwei Tacos wir
haben natürlich die knustrigen Tortilla
Chips zwei verschiedene Burritos eine
Burrito baue die Salz das dazu wir
lassen es uns jetzt richtig gut gehenil
ich muss wirklich sagen ich fühle mich
gerade sofort nach Amerika versetzt das
war so wie als der erste pifgeis in
Deutschland aufgemacht hat bin ich nach
Oberhausen Gefahren Oberhausen bin ich
zu pfeifgeis Gefahren saß da drin konnte
mein Glück nicht fassen und genauso
fühle ich mich gerade wieder weil ich
liebe Amerika wir waren ja gemeinsam
quasi in Amerika das war schon war schon
sehr sehr geil ich habe auch direkt
diese Vibes gehabt h also s mal Optik
vom Laden ist tatsächlich so ich mag das
diese Flaschen da stehen und so das
finde ich sehr geil und die Leute sind
doch einfach gut drauf Spanisch geredet
sind viar aus Amerika das wä natürlich
krass ja also es ist wirklich was
besonderes und ich weiß noch als F
Deutchland war das ganz besonders und
als es dann irgendwann überall war war
auch dieses Feeling für mich ein
bisschen weg weil mittlerweile ist es
normal deshalb wisst wir das zu schätzen
solange es das hier gibt und testen
zunächst einmal ein paar
tortier die sieht auch wirklich geil aus
sieh richtig gut aus schön stückig mal
anschaut kleinen wahrscheinlich
poriander pieces drin rote Zwiebel
riecht gut das ist NS aus Beutel das
merkst du direkt so Farbe ist krass das
Ding wir haben gesehen es ist fast food
ne es ging verdammt schnell wie lange
haben wir auf unser Essen gewartet
Minuten keine 5 Minuten wirklich auf gar
keinen Fall 5 Minuten und dafür sieht
echt gut aus den ersten Reiter mit auf
uns ich weiß fast nicht was du besser
machen kannst ist ist immer so weiß du
so sich strauen ans Limit zu gehen aber
das ist wirklich schon sehr sehr sehr
sehr gut guck mal das ist ein Avocado
Stück da drin also das ist wirklich kein
ist nicht fertig aus aus der Tüte oder
so frischer Koriander drin alles richtig
geil und das ist das geile ich finde B
irgendwie schade dass bisher nur fastf
zu uns geschafft hat das wirklich dich
kaputt macht ja weil das hier ist
irgendwo also am Ende des Tages ein
Burrito ist der bessere Burger soon das
ja klar das ist ja auch kein schlechtes
Essen guck mal du hast hier braunen Reis
unten drin D hast du Fleisch unten drauf
Proteinquelle dann hast du Bohnen auch
wieder eine geile Proteinquelle klar
Käse und so kann man sich streiten aber
ein bisschen Käse ist ja nichts
Schlechtes dann hast du die frische
Salza knackigen Salat umkrauch und
dieses saucam wo soll da was Schlechtes
dran sein und das macht dich satttimt es
ist wirklich ich auch mit dir an meiner
Seite fühle mich wieder wie in Amerika
ein Traum sch ich weiß nicht in welcher
Reihenfolge das ist aber wir drehen noch
ein weiteres Video mit Bern vielleicht
habt ihr schon gesehen vi kommt noch
Bern zeigt mir sein lieblingsresturant
in Frankfurt da freue ich mich auch
schon sehr drauf und ist immer geil wenn
man mit Bern unterwegs ist folgt ihm
unbedingt mal rein ich verlinke ih
natürlich ganz oben in der Beschreibung
dem Titel aber jetzt machen wir weiter
mit Burritos oder danke
schön wobei bevor wir zu den Burritos
kommen schauen wir uns einmal die tacus
an daran mag ich jetzt schon eine Sache
sehr gerne eine Sache überhaupt nicht
was ich sehr gerne mag das sind softell
Tacos diese die Taco Shell so die
kriegst du bei keine Ahung Taco Bell
oder bei irgendwelchen anderen
mexikanischen Schnellrestaurants aber
das hat nichts mit Tacos zu tun für mich
existieren die gar nicht das kannst du
nicht essen das ist einfach nervig ja
was ein bisschen anders ist das wir
weizentortier maistortier wä natürlich
noch mal eine Schippe geiler und dieser
Salat hat für mich relativ wenig auf dem
Taco zu suchen sorry sie hab mich
gefragt gesagt okay alles gut aber wenn
es ein mexikanischer Taco ist das ist
halt texmx ne das ist amerikanisch
mexikanische Fusion Küche so ein
bisschen von beidem und was mir gerade
noch auf Fall hier hinten steht please
do NOT discard plastic baskets also
alleine dass wir hier so in Plastik
Container und so das alles bekommen und
dass da auch amerikanisch oder auf
Englisch steht dass man es nicht
wegwerfen soll das ist so ich glaube das
kommt so direkt aus dem Franchise in
Amerika sa das ist ja eine nachhaltige
Sache die Dinger werden gespült dann
kriegst du die wieder ja und alles
andere ist hier aus diese dieser Pappe
quasi wieder verwendbar bzw
wiederverwend auf der einen Seite hier
ist es kompostierbar auf der anderen und
du kriegst echt das Dreck noch ne du
hast du go natürlich Holz jetzt noch
kein Plastik gesehen alfolie ist das
einzig wo Stre kann aber
aber auch diese klassische
pfeifgeistalufoli so dann schauen wir
uns jetzt mal unsere Tacos an wir haben
natürlich oben drauf den shreded lettuce
ich muss schon muss auf Englisch
sprechen Rig einmal richtig
raus dereg was wir haben darin Crem
fresch dann haben wir Hähnchen Guacamole
paar Zwiebeln wie man es halt macht wir
haben bei allem gesagt ja wollt ihr Mais
ja ich kann nicht wollt ihr Käse ja
wollt ihr ja wollt ihregal rein einfach
da gehe ich auch einfach mal rein im
Prinzip haben die einfach so in ihrer
Auslage ein paar frische Zutaten
vorbereitet schmeiß die ein Burrito die
schmeißen wie ein Taco in eine Bowl am
Ende des Tages wenn da die Qualität
stimmt ist es ja geil let's try Junge
der läuft aber auch hinten schon der
saagtig
überrascht dich das Chicken auch so
krass super saftig aber was das für ein
Punch richtig das ist chifole Adobo
chickenfach schön scharf Alter hat eine
Schärfe krasse Wirklichkeit schmeckt
nach viel mehr als man denkt ich find
die sehen ein bisschen geschmacklos aus
wenn man die sieht ja ich hätte den
Salaten nicht oben drauf machen sollen
der hat irgendwie die Optik auch noch
ein bisschen versautt egal aber ich kann
nicht nein sagen richtig geil ich fühle
den sehr ich finde ih super lecker und
dieses Adobo chicken wow ohne Witz ja es
hat frischpauer das wirkt vielleicht
jetzt auch wie wie Werbung oder so aber
für mich ist das gerade so ich Gert
darin auf also wenn ich das jetzt mit
allen Burritos und allen Tacos
Vergleiche ist das natürlich nicht unter
den besten aber ich fühle diesen Moment
gerade deshalb seh mir nach dass ich
gerade einfach alles Feier du hast dich
ja auch richtig drauf gefreut
hierherzukommen ne also das schon krass
ja wenn ich Bernt W würde ich sagen
dafür komme ich hierher sehr sehr geil
oder burito erst die ich w gerade sagen
erst h die Arbeit dann das Vergnügen
aber du hast ja dein eigenen take auf
buritos ne GU mal das ist ja wie ein
romantisches Date hier zu zweit und dein
Tag so weiß Du das Ding ist nächst mal
bringen wir noch ein Mal Kerzchen mit
oder so alter guck mal Alter was Hal
drin no
joke kanitas also Schwein okay jetzt
schck da ist auch ordentlich was drauf
guck mal wie das zerfällt da kann sich
wirklich das eine oder andere Fastfood
Konzept davon abschneiden es geht
schnell es ist gutes Produkt schönes
saftiges pullpk ja ja hat echt aus Stück
Hähnchen ne hell ja ja ich hab gar nicht
mitbekommen das ja auch ein
Qualitätsmerkmal letlich schönes helles
Schweinefleisch warte mal ich finde das
gerade übelst krank geh mal rein Bro das
ist Pulover das ist so soft neimm dir
mal so ein größeres Stückchen davon h
Alter das Ding ist man ist das Schulter
oder Nacken oder Schulter Nacken oder
Schulter ich hatte gerade so ein richtig
schönes fettes Stück Schweinefleisch das
ist super juicy das steht jetzt hier
seit mindestens 20 Minuten und es war da
vorne noch warm gehalten also das ist
schon das außer gewöhlich oh hier ist
die bell pepper mit drin ja oh ja geil
so eine schöne grü paika die Bohnen der
braune Reis das mag ich eh dass du die
Wahl hast zwischen weißen und braunen
Reis für mich immer ein klares brauner
Reis ich find der schmeckt intensiver du
tust dir irgendwie noch was Gutes damit
ne nicht so high process food bin ich
dabei und h auf jeden Fall gutes
Mittagessen und hier merke ich gerade
ohne Witz wie sehr ich Bay Area in Köln
vermisse es gibt andere burritoläden
aber die kommen nicht daran so dieser
Tex Max tak so dieses es ist im Prinzip
alles mexikanisch bis dann saucam und
Salat und dieser geriebene Käse dazu
kommt aber diese Geschmackskombination
ist einfach richtig schön spicy Alter
ich glaube ich muss jetzt immer
hierherken wenn ich in Frankfurt bin das
freut mich sehr weil wenn immer du
hierherkst ru mich einfach an ich komme
gerne mit kommst dazu das Perfect Schle
schau mal hier wir haben Fleisch wir
haben wir haben Mais wir haben Salat wir
haben Bohnen das ist Käse mit drauf wir
haben sauercam und jetzt
ob jetzt nimmt er mich richtig aus der
Welt Z Glück heute NS mehr vor
das war geil also wow ich bin wieder in
Amerika es ist einfach es ist gut wir
müssen gleich noch mal was zum Preis
sagen auch auch eine interessante
Geschichte ne hab jetzt gar nicht auf
dem Schirm was es gekostet hat alles
zusammen 75 € mit Getränken für se
Personen wir sind mit sechs Leuten hier
hinter der Kamera auch voll okay dafür
dass es frisch gesund ist bist du besser
beraten als mit einem macmenü wer ist
das ja also ne richtiges Essen ja der
Burrito ich sag dir eh der kommt mit wie
Neugeborenes komm mit 4 500 g locker
daher safe safe safe safe safe der ist
aber auch straf gerollt der läuft jetzt
noch nicht aus macht man das wie so ein
dürm dann oder ja also ich mach das
immer so genau das ich mach immer so
gern dass ich so eine Hälfte mir einmal
anreiße wie Weihnachten kannst schön
einmal auspacke Stk da sind die Babys
ich bin echt gespannt was du sagst
dieser knebrige tortier einfach perfekt
abgebissen ja hast du gut gemacht normal
ne ist gar nicht so einfach Spaß du weiß
doch du ziehst doch dann da dran ich
weiß genau was du meinst reiß du
auseinander hier macht dann f die
scheiße da rein dir Gabel we 100% was du
meinst also wenn man selbst zu Hause mal
boritos gemacht hat das sind andere
tortier sind andere teigflag das macht
einfach ein Unterschied und hier hast du
wirklich der erste bis sofort alles drin
was das Herz begehrt ich habe da jetzt
auch barabaco drin also quasi dieses
langsam geschmorte rinfleisch ich muss
sagen ich find's geil oh du hattest ja
was kritisches steakwifel ich hatte die
steakwiürfel wir haben hinten gesehen
dass er gerade frische steakwürfel
geschnitten hatte und ich habe die
bekommen die aber noch vorne drin lagen
und sag dir was das ist super medium
gebraten ich glaube dass sie auch immer
nur so eins zwei Steaks machen vorne
reinlegen und erst wenn das leer wird
werden die Neues machen du garantieren
die halt den Durchlauf und ich sag mal
so so viel stuff wie die hier rumlaufen
haben da muss es auch funktionieren DAV
abgesehen auch immer ein geiles Merkmal
für ein schönes Restaurant blitzsuber
Glasfenster blitzsauber nichts zu
verstecken alle sehen ordentlich aus
weiß das ist für mich natürlich auch das
trägt dazu bei dass ich mehr Appetit
habe einfach ne ich glaube in der ein
oder anderen systemgast sieht vielleicht
nicht so gut aus des ist auch kein
Fenster und das hat mich auch überrascht
wir haben wirklich ein Steak gegrillt
und geschnitten leider waren die Kameras
noch nicht am laufen aber du hast
gesehen dass sie das da geschnitten
haben und frisch gegrillt haben das ist
schon geil ich finde wirklich qualitativ
alle Einzelkomponenten das ist für mich
die beste Fastfoodkette ich find's geil
Leute wie lange kann man über Burritos
Tacos reden wir sind zu einem Ende
gekommen wir hatten ein köstliches
Erlebnis hier bei chipodle ich bin nicht
bezahlt ich find es einfach geil ich
würde mich freuen wenn es das bald
irgendwie auch mal in Köln geben würde
oder in anderen Städten in Deutschland
ansonsten ber haben wir ab sofort ein
regelmäßiges day e geil treffen uns
immer hier guckt euch das andere Video
an was wir heute noch drehen wenn ihr
euch wundert warum mein T-Shirt weckig
ist wegen
Chip und schaut euch Berns ganzen Kanal
an der werd es nicht bereuen Herz Dank
dafür haut rein ciao